une décharge au nord-est du pays
un bout de terre des déchets synonyme
souvent d'espoir nous venons ici tous
les matins pour ramasser les restes et
le plastique et les ramener à la maison
pour les vendre et gagner notre vie
parfois nous trouvons de la nourriture
et la mangeons et nous la donnons même à
nos enfants à la maison s'il y en a
assez
malheureusement ce n'est pas suffisant
pour nous café la série meurtrie depuis
dix ans par un conflit aux différents
acteurs internationaux et aux images
impressionnantes
[Musique]
une population syrienne qui souffre une
famine qui menace
il ya un an l'onu informé que pour le
seul mois de janvier 2020 plus d'un
million de personnes avaient déjà reçu
une assistance alimentaire par le biais
des mécanismes transfrontières un record
depuis 2014 en 2021
l'organisation des nations unies
s'inquiètent des futures livraisons de
médicaments ou d'équipements
hospitaliers menacés par une loi votée
par l'administration troll je crains que
les sanctions imposées en vertu du césar
acte n'exacerbe la situation humanitaire
déjà désastreuse en syrie en particulier
au cours de la pandémie de covile 19 et
ne fasse courir au peuple syrien
un risque encore plus grand de
violations des droits de l'homme
entrée en vigueur le 17 juin en 2020 le
césar acte vise à sanctionner tout
individu entité ou société qui
entretiennent des relations économiques
avec damas ce qui pourrait freiner
d'investisseurs ou organisme à
participer à la reconstruction de la
syrie par peur de représailles
aujourd'hui un appel est lancé à
emmanuel macron ou encore joe biden plus
de 90 personnalités des patriarches
orientaux des évêques mais aussi des
parlementaires des diplomates ou encore
des professeurs d'université des
millions de syriens très durement
affectée iront se coucher ce soir en
ayant faim et froid les sanctions
coercitives unilatérales imposées par
les états unis rendent encore pire la
détresse économique du peuple syrien
nous vous conjurons monsieur le
président d'eads et les syriens à
alléger ou crise humanitaire qui menace
d'entraîner une nouvelle vague
d'instabilité au moyen-orient et au-delà
le nouveau secrétaire d'état américain
et bras droit de joe biden anthony
blinken a affichée ces derniers - ses
ambitions d'être davantage présents aux
côtés du peuple syrien
cette semaine sous l'égide de l'onu le
comité constitutionnel syrien créé en
septembre 2019 se réunit à genève
une cinquième fois représentants du
gouvernement de l'opposition et de la
société civile se retrouve avec l'espoir
pour de véritables négociations